1995 la première page de la forêt des
livres se tourne dans les années qui
suivent moins de 10000 visiteurs et une
trentaine d'écrivains à peine
participent annuellement à cette
manifestation culturelle et bucolique
mais dans les années 2000 ce rendez vous
annuel prend un nouveau virage écrivain
médiatique vedette de la télé du cinéma
s'y succèdent attirant de plus en plus
de monde
parmi eux richard bohringer patrick
poivre d'arvor un habitué et gendarmes
sont ainsi que patrick de carolis mais
aussi charles aznavour qui reviendra
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises puis
line renaud et michel drucker et ce ne
sont là que quelques uns de ces people
venus pour dédicacer leurs ouvrages ou
tout simplement des engagements et
platanes à la rencontre de leur public